hi this is dominic gianciolo i'm the
story and voiceover director for another
realm studios
uh today we're going to be talking about
mortal kombat 11 and mortal kombat 11
aftermath
and looking at how we put together our
time traveling narrative
that merges uh the path to mortal kombat
with president mortal kombat
and allows it is to honor the entire
history of the franchise
the original mortal kombat story was a
smaller affair it revolved around a
small number of warriors who were an
exclusive tournament
that was fought to determine the fate of
the universe
from the beginning uh mortal kombat has
really leaned into its story you know
from mortal kombat 1
when there was just the small character
bios and the endings
that were there even that small amount
of storytelling was something that
really really resonated with the early
fans of the game
and as the franchise has grown and as
the as we've added characters
you know a lot of thought has gone into
making our
universe as rich as it could be and he's
making it as interesting as it can be
for players to follow on because we know
that players are going to
engage more when they're emotionally
invested characters in our universe
but we sat down to write mortal kombat
11. we explored a number of different
possibilities and we pitched a number of
things to ed to see where he might want
to go and the
past meets present angle of the story is
something that ed
got very excited about early on and was
something we were also very excited
about as well
you know from a story standpoint it
allowed us to celebrate the entire
history of mortal kombat
you know we can draw sharp contrast from
where our characters started and where
they are now
and because uh mortal kombat 11 and of
course aftermath are time travel stories
you know we definitely buffed up on and
all of the classics that we're all fans
of whether that's the
future series or the terminator or most
recently the ryan johnson's film looper
from just a few years ago which was a
really an excellent film
obviously you can see the the
fingerprints and back to the feature too
all over aftermath
in terms of having to go back in the
past and find this thing and keep it
from the bad guys but then in terms of
this notion of past meets present
you know that's one of the things that
looper did incredibly powerfully and
when you see
uh old joe and young joe meet bruce
willis and joseph
levitt and that dinah for the first time
you know that is that confrontation
it's the same person at different points
in their lives incredibly different
perspectives
and you know that conflict that kind of
conflict
is something that we knew was going to
be part of
the mortal kombat 11 narrative because
of this past it was present
and provided an excellent inspiration
and a springboard for those kinds of
thinking without it so in the time
travel story like this or rather a
time-mashing story like this
a character like johnny cage is sort of
the prime example of something that
was very fertile ground for this kind of
exploration you know when johnny cage
first appeared in mortal kombat
you know he's the cocky movie star
who's got he's very funny and very
acidic and very immature
dad always said hungry people eat lunch
humble people serve it dad was an
[ __ ] hollywood made
us an even bigger one
yeah and then as we began that story
again
in the rebirth of combat and then took
him into more combat x
we got to sort of push him 25 years into
the future at that point
and see what an older wiser you know
more mature
johnny cage looks like and how he's
going to behave
so we had a very natural contrast
between
young johnny and old johnny and what
they were like that woman over there
she's the real deal oh i got eyes
brother
this younger you i saw him you swear to
tap that at the earliest opportunity
this course is our young johnny cage i
know when they were starting the art for
this they were really sort of leaning
into
the early representations of the
characters in the game going all the way
back to mk1 and nk2
and coming up with a modern presentation
on how they would look how they should
look you know i think
our team did an amazing job of just sort
of encapsulating you know this young gun
johnny
who is so egotistical that he's got his
own name tattooed on his chest
this is the same name i mean everything
about this
screams ego and cockiness and rashness
it just
sums him up to the tv i think they did a
really great job with how he looks
in game and so when you see that
contrast between this johnny and the
golden
trojan it just really pops
when we were able to take the older
giant the older wiser johnny
and force him to be back in place with
his younger version of himself
a version of himself he's probably
wanted to forget even existed or maybe
wasn't as bad as he thought it was
to come together and to deal with that
it just provided a natural conflict
where
our old john almost becomes a surrogate
dad for young johnny and trying to get
him to
sort of man up and be the guy that he
knows that it should be
now that he's got a lot more years under
his belt this is of course our present
day johnny cage he still has an attitude
hence the extended middle finger
but you know you can see just how much
he's grown up his palate is much more
muted his clothes are more
practical than his younger counterpart
and you don't have all of the
self-aggrandizing you know
johnny cage elsewhere he's letting his
actions speak louder than his attire
these days and it shows up everywhere in
his entire costume
as we're looking at what an older johnny
would be like what he would be like as a
dad
you know what is going to be a more
interesting experience to show
him with a daughter or him with a son
and you know given his whole sort of
tomcat
past and how he's with women in
particular but giving him a daughter
like that was going to force him to grow
up and change more than having a son
would be where if he had a son he might
just sort of lean into his tomcatch
behavior
and not really change and so that was
for us like okay giving him a daughter
really allows us to to take him at a
different direction
i need to provide for you in the manner
to which you become accustomed then
geez guys i'm right here originally in
the story development of mortal kombat
11.
this notion that kronecker had had
multiple timelines and that she had a
sort of noodling on
timeline and timelines and fate between
each generation wasn't part of the
original story it really was just one
time then that we restarted
but as we were looking at how we wanted
to deal with the conflict between liu
kang and raiden
and this transition of what we call
light raid and
normal raid into dark breed and over the
course of the story we still realize
it's like wait a minute as we look at
the last several games and even
prior to the modern story mode here
there are so many times where
liu kang and raiden have have been
coming conflict with each other and like
they're fighting over the you know
themselves fighting up to what the
fate of the realms might be and so you
know it is always an odd thing when you
have
two heroes sort of come to blows for
something that's very important like
that that's sort of committing
mortal kombat civil war and so that's
wait a minute you know we've done this
before this beat has reoccurred you know
that sort of unlocked this idea
of the multiple iterations and as we
were writing that was sort of fresh when
the first season of westworld had just
come out and i sort of got through to
the end of that
and i was like oh yes this idea here
that they're using
totally applies back to how our mortal
kombat narratives work and how we sort
of have some of these beats that come
back
cross titles having to be part of what
is kronecker's plan
sort of tied everything together across
multiple narratives you know going from
before the mortal kombat reboot in
aftermath we had a great opportunity
to do some new things with characters
that haven't had a lot of screen time
over the last few games
it was shang tsung in mortal kombat 11.
he has not been in our last couple of
games because we killed him back off at
mk9 so he hasn't been around for a while
but
when we discovered that kerry tagawa had
signed on to return
to play shang tsung we knew that
shanghai had to be
a major portion of the aftermath story
and his inclusion was made easy of
course because shinsuke is one of our
primary villains and they always kind of
think of things so we had to create the
aftermath story such that
he could be right there having worked
with cronica and sort of have the
information
that everybody else needs and help us to
defeat peronica
knowing all the while that at some point
he's gonna double crosses i must ask
sorcerer
how long before you betray us
i find your lack of faith amusing
writing a character like shang tsum who
is always scheming
everybody also knows that he's working
this plan so they're expecting him to
eventually portray them
writing a character like that is
interesting because you always have to
give just enough
you know rope for the audience enough
rope for the characters for
shangston to believe that he could be
trusted like at each of these moments
that okay
we'll go further and so what he's doing
basically is he's playing this long con
and he's getting people to just trust
him enough to get him to this next stage
until he reaches the point where he
doesn't need anybody's trust anymore and
then he can flip on it
so by bringing nightwolf and fuji in
along with him and
creating the lore that cronica had to
keep basically all
all three of them out of the way and put
them over in the void for safe keeping
while she didn't plan
by their arriving with shang and be
independent validators for what he's
seen and what he's talking about
gives liu kang and raiden a reading to
trust shang tsu
for now and allow him to begin this
quest
and then of course they are functioned
as the chaperones for shang tsung to
make sure that he stays on the straight
and narrow
over the course of the adventure
nightwolf as well you know we we're
trying to also shake him
a little bit more and ground him a
little bit more even
back in mk9 because he's sort of this
god-like character he is also very much
like braden
and we were trying to ground him a bit
and make him feel
a little more fully realized and simply
clone with green
so that's why we introduced this notion
of the mantle we gave nightwolf this
backstory it's great cloud
to try to give him a little more
richness give him more to work with so
that
as we saw him in the scenes as we dealt
with him at the intros there was just
more risk there to explore who he is
what he's looking for and where he sort
of fits in the more confident universe
in the case of fujin this is his longest
portrayal and the most in-depth
portrayal
that he's had really since he's been
introduced as a character
and so our challenge here was
differentiating fujian
from reagan and how do we make sure that
these two protectors of earth around
these two gods do not feel like the same
person
and that's when we decided to shade
fujin in a more relatable way somebody
that is less aloof
somebody that is more in tune with
humanity in a way that perhaps raiden
isn't
and making him more accessible the big
change that we had
between these stories is the moment of
course where
president jax is brought back from
kernich's side back to the good guys
side
now the main story that happens on the
ships as they're heading off to
chronicle's keep
jax battles raiden and braden convinces
jax to come back to his side
in the aftermath that beat happens a
little bit earlier when fujin and shang
tsung
nightwolf are yet the well of souls and
shanks island
they encounter present jacks and fujin
is the one to bring
present jax back now the the content of
the conversation is a bit different in
terms of
how each is trying to bring jax back
fujin's
focuses much more on his empathy for
jacks in that situation
you're a god ain't no way you get how
this feels
you know the only time raiden and i ever
fought
when i left the sky temple to live among
humans
and not only is do you see that present
in the dialogue but you also see it in
the physical
in the blocking for the braden and
jack's feet and raiden is
standing over jax as jax is sort of on
the ground
fujian on the other hand when he goes to
bring jax back to the fold
you know he goes down next to jax he
goes down on one knee he brings himself
down to jax's level
that gives us this great contrast
between how raven deals with people and
how
huge and deals with people and allowed
us to take an entirely different attack
in that conversation
how fujin is recruiting and i mean of
all the moments that sort of
differ between main story and aftermath
story
that's that's the biggest one and i
think it's an incredibly powerful moment
because we get to see
not only this difference between fujin
and raiden
but also really get to see you know
fujin's heart in a way
that has not been exposed in any more
content today
and uh it was great to be able to plumb
that depth
we start talking about my mortal kombat
11 and the legacy that this story has
i i think what we want to hope for is
that it really has
sort of encapsulated the entire history
of mortal kombat
up to this point being true to where we
have been and
showing a really strong sense of
presence of where mortal kombat is
and also you're pointing away towards
more important combat might go
in the future it has been tremendous for
us given just how well the game's been
received to be able to have a chance to
do this
and we hope that this is what's going to
stick in people's minds going forward
[Music]
you